prince harry and meghan markle welcomed
their second child a daughter named
lillabet lily diana on june 4th
and now a source is telling et that
harry's grandmother queen elizabeth was
their first call
the couple have named their daughter
lilybert
diana mountbatten windsor which is
quite a royal name the source says that
the duke and duchess of sussex
introduced their little bundle of joy to
the queen over a video call
quote the duke spoke with his family in
advance of the announcement
in fact his grandmother was the first
family member he called
of course the couple explained in a
statement that their daughter's name
sweetly honors queen elizabeth ii and
harry's mom
the late princess diana lillabet is
harry's grandmother's family nickname
and diana was chosen to honor harry's
late mother
i've long heard that if prince harry
ever had a little girl
he was always going to honor his
mother's name and give her diana as one
of her names but i think the greatest
surprise has been lily bert which
actually many people don't even know
is an affectionate nickname that was
given to the queen when she was little
she couldn't pronounce elizabeth it came
out lily bette
when she was just two and it was such a
cute and lovely name it's stuff
but the name lilibet has stirred up some
mixed reactions with critics saying the
name is deeply personal to the queen
i think we all expected diana to be in
there
somewhere within the naming of their
little girl but
lily has come really as a huge surprise
and it does come
i think with a bit of controversy
attached to it to say the least because
it is
a very private very personal nickname
and for the queen very very few people
ever refer to the queen as lily bet
in fact prince philip really was the
last person to
so it is incredibly significant i think
that they've chosen lily best some
people feel
that perhaps the sussexes have
overstepped the mark
in giving their daughter the queen's
favorite and most personal
of all nicknames but a source who is
close to the sussexes tells e.t
that had the queen not been supportive
of the name they wouldn't have used it
it is my understanding that harry did
seek his grandmother's blessing
to use the name lilybet for their
daughter
who did speak to her about it and the
family were all notified
ahead of the birth but harry did have
that conversation i understand
with his grandmother to make sure that
he had her blessing in the naming of
their daughter
following the birth of megan and harry's
daughter the royal family took to social
media to congratulate the couple
and a source told et that while they
made a coordinated public effort to
congratulate and offer harry and megan
well wishes
there are still lingering feelings of
disappointment and anger
after the couple's claims in their
explosive oprah interview
where they accused an unnamed member of
the royal family of expressing concern
about the potential color of their son
archie's skin before he was born
everyone's hope is that this little baby
is going to be
a rift healer um because this
family division has really gone on for a
very long time now it's well over a year
we know that there have been some really
quite deep problems between harry and
william
difficulties between harry and his
father and i think it's everyone's
hope that this little baby will will be
a peace offering
in many ways and that she will help to
bring this divided family
back together